salut romain ça va je crois que j'ai
deviné tout seul tu as quoi exactement
un peu de température et c'est mal à
corps à corps genre une angine quoi je
sais pas du tout une maladie rare par
contre si parce que d'habitude je suis
jamais malade
ah voilà il était sûr du coup c'est rare
oui oui de nos rejets et comme je suis
malade ces maladies rares
voilà j'ai mais n'ont vraiment pas du
tout c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
du coup quelques vous savez ce que c'est
le 1er octobre c'est l'anniversaire dans
mes livres
en fait non c'est pas ça 6 mais on s'en
fout on s'en fout pas et sûrement très
sympa audrey veilleux mais non c'est pas
ça le sujet vous le 1er octobre c'est la
journée internationale de la maladie de
gaucher et vous savez pas ce que c'est
la maladie coché la maladie de gaucher
ça n'a rien à voir avec la main dont
vous vous servez pour écrire on pour
tout le reste ça c'est pas une maladie
la maladie de gaucher c'est une maladie
génétique la maladie de gaucher c'est
une maladie lysosomale ou lysosomales on
va juste l'appeler la maladie de gaucher
il en existe trois types le premier qui
est le plus fréquent parce qu'il touche
95 % des malades et deux autres formes
qui sont plus rares et plus grave et qui
touche le système nerveux
bon mais je sens que je vous ai titiller
avec cette histoire de maladies
lysosomales ou mialhe voulez savoir
vieux curieux vous voulez comprendre
écouter c'est pour ça que j'ai pour
schématiser la maladie de gaucher elle
entraîne un déficit d'une enzyme dont on
se sert pour dégrader certaines
substances qui du coup s'accumulent dans
les lits zone et les lysosomes c'est des
composants d'un certain nombre de nos
cellules et du coup les cellules en
question elles fonctionnent plus
correctement et en l'occurrence à touche
essentiellement les cellules du foie de
la rate et de la moelle osseuse
les signes de la maladie de gaucher ça
peut être de la fatigue des douleurs et
une fragilité
niveau des eaux souvent dans les jambes
ou le bassin mais aussi le ventre qui
grossit et qui devient douloureux et des
problèmes au niveau des éléments qui
composent le sang et qui sont fabriqués
dans la moelle osseuse comme une baisse
du nombre de globules rouges ou des
problèmes de coagulation avec des
saignements au niveau des gencives et du
nez par exemple ou avec des hématomes
qui apparaissent comme ça sans se cogner
nirere bon mais vous savez pourquoi vous
saviez pas tout ça pourquoi vous
connaissiez pas la maladie de gaucher
parce que la maladie de gaucher c'est
une maladie rare pour vous donner une
idée on dit qu'une maladie est rare
quand elle touche moins d'une personne
sur 2000 et la maladie de gaucher elle
touche une personne sur 60 milles dans
le monde en france et touche 500
personnes donc vous voyez c'est rare
alors vous allez me dire oui mais bon
quand on est malade que la maladie soit
rare ou pas c'est pareil on est malade
et je vais vous répondre
et ben non et ben non mais pour
comprendre pourquoi on va faire un
rapide petit rappel sur ce qui se passe
quand on est malade
quand vous êtes malade vous allez chez
le médecin et la première chose que doit
faire le médecin pour savoir comment
vous soigner c'est de trouver quelle
maladie vous avez ça s'appelle faire un
diagnostic pour ça il va vous poser des
questions et nous examiner pour trouver
les signes et symptômes que vous avez
depuis combien de temps à quelle
occasion ils sont apparus et c'est
parfois ça suffit si les signes sont
clairement ceux d'une maladie précise le
médecin a posé son diagnostic emballé
c'est pesé
mais parfois c'est un peu plus compliqué
si un doute ou s'il faut plus de
renseignement pour être sûr le médecin
peut demander des examens comme une
radio une échographie
hahn air etc ou des analyses comme des
prises de sang ou d'autres trucs
et là encore si les résultats et les
symptômes colle parfaitement avec ceux
d'une maladie hop le diagnostic est posé
mais parfois c'est un peu plus compliqué
ça peut arriver que les signes les
résultats des examens et des analyses
mais il colle pas de façon évidente avec
la check list d'une maladie connue donc
le médecin peut vous envoyer voir un
spécialiste en fonction du genre de
signe que vous avez là le spécialiste et
autres monstres où il fait à peu près la
même démarche
sauf que bon c'est un spécialiste il est
habitué aux trucs un peu plus pointue
dans son domaine donc hop y trouve
et bim diagnostic vous savez ce que vous
avez mais parfois c'est un peu plus
compliqué parfois le spécialiste il
trouve pas non plus donc vous allez voir
un autre spécialiste puis un autre puis
un autre parfois personnes trouvent
parfois on finit par vous dire que c'est
dans votre tête
parfois vous lâchez rien et on finit à
trouver alors le temps entre le moment
où on commence à chercher et où on
trouve ça s'appelle l'errance
diagnostique pierre lapin avaient très
bien raconter tout ça dans la vidéo dans
laquelle il nous parlait de sa
myopathies de becker je vous remets le
lien dans la description de la vidéo et
je vous invite à retourner la regarder
et bah quand on a une maladie rare cette
errance diagnostique
elle dure en moyenne quatre ans voire 10
pour la maladie de gaucher dix ans à se
demander ce qu'on a à avoir peur de
jamais trouvé à douter à s'inquiéter
c'est hyper lent surtout que pendant ce
temps là vu qu'on sait pas ce que vous
avez bas qu'on peut pas vous soigner oui
parce que c'est pas mal à ça que ça sert
un diagnostic quand on connaît la
maladie on connaît le traitement a donné
avant orientale oui parce qu'un autre
truc pénible avec les maladies rares
c'est que il ya des traitements
spécifiques c'est à dire des traitements
vraiment destiné à cette maladie que
pour 5% d'entre elles pour la maladie de
gaucher par exemple il ya des
traitements est plutôt ils sont commencé
plus ils permettent de ralentir les
de la maladie et donc d'éviter des
lésions irréversibles
donc vous voyez l'errance diagnostique
c'est du temps perdu qu'on ne ratera
fait plus mais même pour les maladies
qu'on pas de traitement spécifique
quand non pas encore c'est important
pour la patiente où le patient qui est
un diagnostic et d'être reconnus comme
ayant une maladie rare d'abord parce que
psychologiquement ça enlève un poids
toutes les personnes concernées qui j'en
ai parlé me l'ont dit on n'est pas fous
on a vraiment une maladie existe on va
arrêter de chercher et on est fixé alors
c'est un autre combat qui commence mais
quitte à se battre autant savoir contre
qui on se marre et puis un autre est
positif c'est qu'avoir un diagnostic et
être reconnu comme ayant une maladie
rare ça permet aussi de rentrer dans un
circuit de soins spécialisés c'est à
dire d'avoir une prise en charge
vraiment adapté à sa maladie bénéficier
des traitements spécifiques
quand il y en a et aussi des autres
traitements qui sont pas forcément pile
destiné à la maladie qu'on a mais qui
peuvent aider quand même et qui peuvent
aussi freiner la maladie ou au moins
limiter ses effets ça permet aussi
d'avoir accès aux derniers progrès en
matière de recherche parce que oui quand
même
on va voir de participer à des études
cliniques sur des nouveaux traitements
et puis il ya aussi tout le reste comme
être en lien avec des équipes
spécialisées dans des centres de
référence pour les maladies rares
parce que comme on vient de le dire les
traitements spécifiques de la maladie
c'est pas les seuls traitements qu'on
peut proposer
et puis il ya aussi la kinésithérapie
l'ergothérapie les psychologues etc sans
oublier quelque chose qui peut paraître
anecdotique vu de l'extérieur mais qui
est en réalité hyper important l'accès
aux associations de patients globalement
on est d'accord que quand on vit quelque
chose ça fait du bien d'en discuter avec
des gens qui vivent la même chose
alors imaginez qu'on sait quelque chose
comme une maladie rare un truc éprouvant
un truc qu'on a cru être le nous la
seule à vivre pendant des années rien
que pour ça les associations c'est ultra
important et en plus ça permet d'avoir
des tips des renseignements précieux sur
sa maladie
et sa prise en charge j'ai dit que
c'était hyper important dans le cas qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui
les associations elles se sont même
regrouper en plateforme des maladies
rares je vous mets le lien dans la
description de la vidéo pour celles et
ceux qui sont intéressés donc vous voyez
dans tous les cas le diagnostic une fois
qu'il est posé il change la vie est
plutôt il est posé mieux c'est à tous
points de vue bon mais alors pourquoi
n'y a pas de traitement spécifique pour
les maladies rares
bah déjà pour trouver un traitement pour
en chercher et les chercheurs cherchent
pas quand ils ont envie de chercher
il cherche quand ils ont des
financements pour chercher et les
financements il y en a plus facilement
pour des maladies qui touchent beaucoup
de monde ensuite on parle de maladies
complexes nombreuses mais ça on va y
revenir et qui touchent chacune un petit
nombre de personnes donc pour lancer des
recherches c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
c'est compliqué mais c'est possible
quand même la preuve ya des traitements
spécifiques qui ont été mis au point
pour la maladie de gaucher par exemple
et il y en a aussi pour d'autres
maladies rares il faut savoir qu'en
france on est plutôt à la pointe dans le
domaine des maladies rares
c'est pas tout le temps donc ça vaut le
coup de le dire quand c'est le cas on en
est au troisième plan national maladies
rares depuis 2005 et la france a été le
premier pays d'europe à mettre ça en
place pour créer les centres de
référence dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
pour favoriser la recherche et l'accès
des patients aux derniers progrès et
pour faire baisser les rangs ce
diagnostic
à moins d'un an on n'y est pas encore
mais ça progresse
alors pourquoi on se démène comme ça
pour un truc rares d'abord même si sa
touche et que deux trois personnes
c'est le genre de truc qui sont ne pas
laisser des gens sur le bord de la route
comme ça en leur disant ah ben oui mais
fait rare le démerdez vous et en plus
parce que bon ok les maladies rares
c'est rare mais en fait non je veux dire
les maladies rares elles touchent peu de
personnes chacune
mais les maladies rares y en a six à
huit mille donc au total ça représente 3
millions de personnes en france soit une
personne sur vingt dont la moitié sont
des enfants
ça fait plus de 350 millions
deux personnes atteintes dans le monde
c'est moins rare d'un coup ça peut même
dire que vous connaissez des personnes
qui ont une maladie rare ou que vous en
avez une
peut-être même sans le savoir du coup
bon peut-être que vous ou un de vos
proches est en train de chercher à
comprendre
alors je ne vais pas vous laisser sans
un ou deux petits conseils pratiques
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour essayer
ne pas être embarqué dans une errance
diagnostique ne pas lâcher vous avez
envie vous avez besoin de savoir donc
n'hésitez pas à le dire à votre médecin
comme ça il pourra vous diriger vers le
spécialiste le plus adapté au type de
symptômes que vous avez si besoin vous
allez sûrement voir plusieurs posez leur
des questions diplômes aux difficultés
dites vous que vous n'êtes pas leur seul
patient mais que c'est votre seul santé
donc la charia ne pas se laisser dire
c'est dans votre tête
même si c'était le cas si vous souffrez
vous avez besoin d'être soignée et pour
être soigné faut qu'on trouve ce que
vous avez donc dans la tête ou ailleurs
faut trouver donc faut chercher ne pas
rester seul parlez-en autour de vous
chercher des gens ayant une expérience
similaire à la vôtre
contacté des associations si besoin
certain nombre des forums voir des
plates formes individuelles sur lesquels
vous pourrez poser vos questions là
encore je vous mets des biens dans la
description de la vidéo voit la dtcc
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici
là prenez soin de vous et prenez soin
des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]